[Musique]
lorsqu'un naufrage survient sur les
côtes françaises et qu'il s'agit d'un
bateau de pêche on évoque souvent la
douleur des familles
on parle de l'océan en colère
de la fatalité
[Musique]
mais qui sait vraiment ce qui se passe
au large lorsque la nature se déchaîne
[Musique]
e
pour comprendre ce qui pousse ces hommes
à prendre la mer pour l'un des métiers
les plus dangereux du monde
j'ai choisi les côtes bretonnes que je
connais bien car la mer y est plus
hostiles qu'ailleurs
nous avons filmé au plus près des marins
pêcheurs au travail pour qu'ils me
racontent leurs histoires de mer qu'ils
me parlent de leur métier de leur
relation avec les éléments
ce film révèle un univers à part il
montre le quotidien difficile d'une
poignée d'hommes qui n'a pas froid aux
yeux et qui oublient parfois les limites
du raisonnable
du nord au sud en passant par l'ouest de
la bretagne
trois équipages ont accepté que
j'embarque avec eux le temps d'une marée
hivernale des heures intenses ou quoi
qu'il arrive ce sont les mouvements de
la mer qui décide
le premier de ces équipages m'a donné
rendez vous au petit matin dans un café
du port de paimpol
hf à petit corps tant sa beauté
le gouren vous et bonne humeur et oui
disait dans le tour 2004 qui s'est cassé
la gueule encore quentin newton est
originaire de l'île de bréhat
ce jeune père de famille a été
entraîneur de chevaux maraîchers agents
immobiliers mais depuis longtemps il a
un rêve posséder son propre bateau de
pêche blanche compagnie est partout ce
n'est pas le rassemble les gens interne
aux familles principalement souvent nous
prennes ton je vais je vais dire la
chose ils nous prennent pour des gens un
peu barjot quoi vous êtes un peu dingo
les gars moi je sais que ma femme a
beaucoup de mal à comprendre ce métier
qui était dur qu'est physique on est
souvent écartée
si tu commences à avoir peur de de
l'élément tout à fait gagner ta vie et
qui te fait vivre il faut faire autre
chose il faut changer de métier je sais
que le jour où j'aurai peur de j'aurais
peur mon métier j'arrêterai
en attendant que son rêve se réalise
quand on navigue sous les ordres de jean
jacques prigent
c'est lui qui lui a presque tout appris
peu bavard ce patron est l'un des
meilleurs pêcheurs de coquilles
saint-jacques de toute la région
deux fois par semaine l'équipage de la
rose de jéricho participe à la pêche la
plus dangereuse et la plus réglementée
des côtes françaises
cette pêche a pour décor l'immense baie
de saint brieuc un vaste champ de
bataille où 200 bateaux se livrent une
guerre sans merci
petit détail qui a son importance les
marins n'ont que 45 minutes pour draguer
le fond de l'océan à 45 minutes de trac
pour ramener à terre les plus beaux
spécimens de coquilles saint jacques à
ces hommes jouent donc leur salaire en
très peu de temps et les engins
métalliques ils manipulent sont souvent
à l'origine d'accidents
quarante cinq minutes ça va très vite
on est surtout tendu et speed et bonne
humeur en général
[Musique]
nous sommes à la veille de noël et les
cours de l'aco qui ne sont pas au plus
haut mais à la fin de cette journée les
meilleurs équipages pourront s'en tirer
avec un peu plus de 2000 euros je
comprends mieux désormais les
motivations de pantin malgré le froid et
le danger
mais ce qu'il y ait encore de plus
impressionnant c'est tout le dispositif
mis en oeuvre pour lutter contre la
fraude
les affaires maritimes n'hésite pas à
contrôler les navires quelques minutes
seulement avant l'ouverture officielle
de la pêche
les agents fouillent les cas là à la
recherche d'éventuels coquilles pêchées
pendant la nuit
ils contrôlent les licences vérifie la
sécurité à bord
malheur aux marins qui ne respectent pas
les règles
[Musique]
et puis un peu plus loin dans la baie un
petit cessna fonce en piqué sur les
bateaux affrétés par les pêcheurs
eux-mêmes
il survole la belle à chaque marée afin
d'éviter le pillage d'un des plus grands
gisements de coquilles d'europe passer à
côté
bien sûr mec
il va passer par toulouse l'an les
enfants des fois tu as l'hélico l'avion
le zodiaque la vedette des douanes et
inventa la totale
papy ces sorties sont cons
[Applaudissements]
à l'extrême ouest de la bretagne jean
marc guilcher lui s'apprête à quitter sa
famille pour une petite semaine
pas une fin en soi d'aller risquer sa
vie ou d'aller risquer sa peau dans les
déferlantes et ça fait partie du jeu
c'est arrivé comme ça on dit qu'un jour
je vais de pêcheurs non c'est moi
c'était évident donc tout petit je n'ai
pas souvenir quand ça prouve quand ça a
pu commencer
ça a commencé par apprendre à nager
apprendra godié à manoeuvrer à canotes
aller chercher du bois - la grève pêché
deux ou trois poissons avec un filet
avec un copain à bien comme comme monter
une mayonnaise
j'ai rencontré jean marc par hasard sur
les quais d'audierne
cette force de la nature a grandi ici
sur l'île de sein à chaque grande marée
lorsque les courants sont les plus forts
en mer d'iroise il arme son bateau
jean-marc fait partie des redoutables
pêcheurs de barre l'un des poissons les
plus recherchés des côtes françaises
[Musique]
après une heure de navigation vers le
nord nous apercevons les côtes
déchiquetées de l'île d'ouessant
il ya treize ans j'ai commencé la pêche
au bar à la ligne
quelques petites altercations lazio rome
en 1200 moi je suis
je suis venu ici faire autant
détruis du poisson ici par contre
l'endroit est
vous savez à comparer
lorenza c'est donc ici au pied du phare
du créac'h sur son bateau chimère que
jean marc attend l'arrivée en masse des
fous de bassan
ces oiseaux marins sont le signal que
les bancs de poissons sont en surface
fais attention à toi l'enjeu
si on laisse tomber en travers
c'est le moment qui est le plus
plus agitée
soit on
en quelques secondes une série de vagues
énormes nous font perdre l'équilibré
avant d'embarquer jean-marc nous avait
prévenus en cas de coup dur nous devons
absolument garder une main pour nous et
l'autre pour le bateau
bah écoute là pour éviter deux à prendre
par le travers la chenu bout de deux ans
et on a bien chargé l'accovam
efa bords du lot ça demande beaucoup
d'efforts au bateau est ce qu'il pilote
pour avoir un poisson 12 euros ou 13
euros le kilo dans tellement d'efforts
quand il sait qu'après auprès sonnerie
7,30 euros le kilo ça paraît un peu
dérisoire mais vouloir gagner sa vie en
tenant un fil au bout de sa main mais
pourquoi pas je sais pas c'était
l'avenir bonne conduite pêche douce et
en fin de compte de morts que ce qu'il
veut mordre
pour la première fois nous avons donc
éprouver le danger dans les déferlantes
de la mer d'iroise
la première et certainement pas la
dernière car tout au sud de la bretagne
nous attend à marin pas vraiment comme
les autres thierry béguin pour la mère
comme il entre sur le ring cet ancien
boxeur professionnel pratiquer une pêche
où tous les sens doivent être en éveil
nous prenons la route avec lui en
direction de la côte sauvage de quiberon
à la recherche d'un crustacé étrange
c'est pas un métier kamikazes
contrairement à ce qu'on peut croire tu
t'accroches et où il ya des jours avec
et des jours sans
c'est la lutte c'est la vie c'est comme
ça c'est rien n'est facile je voulais
une masse sombre c'est pareil j'aurais
été mise à l'épreuve au pied du mur
c'est le cas de le dire c'est comme ça
et là ou là
ce que je croyais je pensais il y aurait
plus de rouge
ben un petit peu plus ce qui est
la ja d'omettre ameline
les pouces pieds il se trouve dans les
brisants là où il ya le plus heureux
déferlante plus ça bouge plus ça
bastonne et puis on aura plus et bouger
tous et pluie sera solide et résistant
et de bonne qualité de façon il ya du
bon c'est pas sur du velours
sur une quarantaine de pêcheurs
professionnels
seul thierry et marc ont accepté notre
présence à bord de leur bateau
en bretagne la récolte des pousses qui
est un sujet très délicat c'est une
pêche très lucrative qui n'est ouverte
que 70 jours par an la concurrence est
donc très rude et la fraude
plutôt bien organisé
mais silence de mort adriatico
pour ces faits
y'a pas loin
[Musique]
je comprends que sur le zodiaque
désormais ce sont eux qui mènent la
danse
et apparemment ils ont bien envie d'en
découdre
histoire de nous montrer qu'ils ne sont
plus de simples terriens il ya des trucs
qui sortent naturellement par l'habitude
de faire quoi on n'a pas le même cri
quand on se tape sur la marque quand on
reçoit une déferlante celles qui m'ont
ya celles qui me qui est désagréable et
il ya celles qui risquent de vous
emmener alors que pas pareil
et si c'est rouge et il serront j'ai
rongé ronger pas ce petit caillou n'a
été pas mal
mais apparemment thierry n'est pas le
premier à poser le pied sur le phare de
la teignouse 1 nous écrire tout à
l'heure je vais faire
ouais
on reprend la base là ok là pour pas le
couper voilà le type même de
pouces-pieds que les espagnols recherche
et les petits il est dur il est court il
est passé nier il est bien travaillé
faut être un bon comme moi pour cocher
des comme ça sur le manque ça doit
valeur des sous la presse qu'il ya des
braconniers qui viennent d'espagne ici
mais nous offrir où on est payé et le
nombre de joueurs qu'on a on gagne
levure raisonnablement pas surtout pas
jouer les américains on en est loin
ça y est
la récolte des pouces pieds est
étroitement surveillé par les autorités
maritimes
car ce petit crustacé attire les
convoitises
notamment celle des trafiquants
espagnols qui les ventes chez eux
jusqu'à 300 euros le kilo
salut vous n'avez pas vu de braquo
espagnol embauché par le comité local
des pêches
jean course au fait ce qu'il peut pour
obtenir des informations sur les
tricheurs
oui c'était nous a signalé la beauce est
un péché en boîte un qu'ils à signaler
sauf
je finis par comprendre que le
garde-pêche a déjà quelques indices sur
un petit groupe d'espagnols qui
ratissent la zone depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant
en attendant une bonne prise j'encours
social large entre la trinité et
belle-ile-en-mer à l'affût du moindre
signe de leur présence
[Musique]
il est un peu plus de midi la pression
monte pour quentin et l'équipage de la
rose de jéricho dans quelques secondes
c'est l'ouverture de la pêche à la
coquille
ni qualifiés
mais soudain une alarme retentit c'est
un appel d'urgence
[Musique]
présent sur la zone lors de chaque marée
les sauveteurs en mer sont déjà en route
l'appel radio se précise un homme est
tombé à la mer au beau milieu de la baie
saint brieuc le patron du baltimore
appel au secours
à bord du canot de sauvetage un médecin
se préparent à intervenir
et avant les avants de ban devait
rentrer alors qu'elle demandait
ah bon
je vous le rende au caire
ok
[Musique]
wii party avec la drogue d'ailleurs au
moment où ils ont viré que la drague est
parti dans l'eau lui il a dû suspendre
le client dans la fumée
était parti avec toi
juste avant l'arrivée des sauveteurs
marc thévenet qu'un pêcheur de co qui
s'est dérouté vers le lieu du drame
il a 20 ans je vais partir
mais penser ça
[Musique]
c'était vraiment
un hélicoptère de la marine nationale
est finalement dépêché sur la zone
il va évacuer la victime vers l'hôpital
le plus proche
[Musique]
le marin du baltimore s'en sortira avec
une forte hypothermie et une blessure à
la jambe
à bord de la rose de jéricho jean
jacques et quentin ont suivi le
sauvetage à la radio
ce genre d'accident fait partie des
risques du métier mais en mer comme à
terre
les marins préfère ne pas évoquer la
mort ou le naufrage après l'accident
quentin comme les autres préfèrent se
concentrer sur ses gestes
[Musique]
en mer d'iroise où plus qu'ailleurs la
mer ne pardonne pas jean marc nous a
donné le début d'une réponse quant aux
risques quotidiens d'être emportées par
la mer depuis je suis pêcheur moi j'ai
vu quatre bateaux chavirés à côté de moi
j'en ai vu un perdre sa vie à côté de
moi j'en ai ramassé à note sur l'eau
vivants j'ai vu deux autres bateaux
chavirés les gars ont été sauvés avec
récupérer avec d'autres bateaux voilà
maintenant ça fait partie du jeu en fin
de compte ne nous on pense pas à nous
tant qu' on pense que ça arrive toujours
aux autres c'est on pense pas au danger
quand on y re quand tu as une situation
qui est difficile ou pas les genoux qui
tremblent un peu enfin tu te rends
compte quand même que tu as que tu as
beaucoup de pression que tu te dis merde
qu'est ce que je fous là
[Applaudissements]
sous les déferlantes de la chaussée de
keller l'univers sous marin semble
étrangement calme des bancs de
maquereaux tente de se frayer un chemin
à travers les courants de marée les bars
se cache sous les laminaires il quête
leurs proies
et puis en quelques minutes les courants
s'inverse la mer bouillonne à nouveau
les fous de bassan sont de retour
je regarde les oiseaux mais ceux qui
sont là bas
je suis pas dedans mais je vais
et toi la difficulté c'est de savoir je
vais là où alors ça va chasser ici dans
5 minutes ou dans dix secondes mais ça
tu fais ok je suis je fais pas
le stif le stif du chimères latour radar
du stiff à ouessant réguler le trafic
des cargos qui entrent ou qui sortent de
la manche mais les agents des affaires
maritimes ont toujours un oeil sur ce
qui se passe en contrebas dans la
chaussette keller pour l'instant jean
marc s'est mise à l'abri car la mer
devient forte
c'est facile à ceux subis en fin de
compte un mois j'ai souvenir d'un gars
qui me demandaient combien il fallait
dans la journée pour gagner ma vie de
lui avoir répondu que je prenais que ce
qu'on me donnait de toute façon donc
donc je trouve ça c'est ce qui fait le
charme de ce métier là
[Musique]
nous rentrerons tire et marque dans la
brume
d'accord
ça continue
mais péter fura oui
pour eux aussi c'est le moment de la
journée où les courants sont les plus
forts
là où l'ue grossi de minute en minute
coucou
il
oui
parfois le métier tellement dur dans le
froid les conditions difficiles avec une
météo dangereuse pour tous a
principalement
quand c'est tout un ensemble du froid
des dangers et des petites pêcheries
effectivement il ya des moments n'aime
pas du tout on voudrait travailler un
peu plus souplement ou du moins une voie
dangereuse
et puis soudain le zodiac sur lequel
nous nous trouvons est aspiré par la mer
rien
c'est le genre d'instant au tout peut
basculer
nous sommes littéralement soulevés par
les déferlantes
et juste avant que le bateau ne se
retourne marque sont à bord in extremis
merci de votre
nous sommes sains et saufs mais marque
doit maintenant aller chercher thierry
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard une autre
lame de fond l'emportent
[Musique]
un comble
à
[Musique]
je croyais qu'ils larguent avec enfin
quoi
obama rouge suis pas ce que tu en penses
viactive et dessus c'est chaud on a de
la chance d'être et vous avec cette fois
nous n'en menions pas large
[Musique]
comme thierry j'ai encore en mémoire les
images du naufrage qui s'est déroulé il
ya quelques jours sur ces récifs
son matériel
alors qu'il manoeuvrait dans les
déferlantes près de la côte belliloise
deux marins originaires de l'île de
houat ont été emportés par une vague
plus grosse que les autres
[Musique]
tous un moment ou un autre on a failli
passer aussi quoi donc
hier c'était pascal et son gant on va
pas dire je vais pas dire demain sera un
autre mais la mer était plus forte
voilà
un peu plus au nord
jean courseaux le garde-pêche est
toujours en veille sur la côte sauvage
de quiberon
garde un petit peu parce que
jamais
mr aujourd'hui
un accident est vite arrivé avec
l'émission de speed
donc je suis pas là que pour les
contrôler je suis là aussi pour les
sauver leur vie aussi
s'ils ont besoin de moi
avec le vent qui creuse la maire la
situation devient périlleuse pour les
rares pêcheurs de pouces pieds qui sont
de sortie
en baie de saint brieuc sur la rose de
jéricho le froid et la fatigue commence
à se faire sentir
entre deux coups de drague quentin
s'accordent une prison
[Musique]
réponse les terrains d'affrontement
pour les chapelles et bonjour
satan comme en province
malgré sa bonne humeur les ennuis ne
vont pas tarder à commencer pour lui car
désormais ce ne sont plus des coquilles
saint jacques mais d'énormes blocs de
roche qui s'accumulent sur le pont
dangereux pour nous quand il ya ce temps
là c'est quand les dragons d'abord
parce que quand elle monte d'abord c'est
quoi
avec le voulez bien sûr
pour y est c'est fait
[Applaudissements]
les miens sont le tir au filet rouge
pourpre et arrive à faire les beaux
poissons
tu peux faire des fois c'est ce cas ce
sont 150 et au pardon
au bout de trois minutes
c'est quand même impressionnant quand tu
fais trois très conscients des gens
tapaient chez les souris
les équipages non plus que 25 minutes
pour ratisser le fonds de la bei
le rythme s'accélère car chaque drague
remonter à bord représente des centaines
d'euros en plus
[Musique]
mais cette fois la rose de jéricho est
en très mauvaise posture
son grand râteau d'assises vient de
s'accrocher au fond de la mer
elles ont quant à elles
à l'arrière quentin passe à deux doigts
de la catastrophe
jean-jacques stoppe son moteur et donne
du mou dans ces câbles
arriva
[Musique]
la fed en s'accrochant l'écaillon
je mesure à quel point jean jacques et
les autres gardent leur sang-froid dans
de telles situations
une fois de plus nous avons eu de la
chance seuls des marins expérimentés
peuvent se sortir de ce genre de piège
et faire ainsi un beau bras d'honneur au
destin
au pied du phare du créac'h la pêche au
bar a repris de plus belle
les marins ne sont plus tellement
nombreux sur la zone mais jean marc lui
profite des courants favorables
nous assistons alors un véritable rodéo
tous les mauvais coups sont permis
[Musique]
certains pêcheurs n'hésitent pas à
passer sur la ligne d autres en fait
chacun se bat pour préserver son terrain
de chasse car les places sont chères à
la pêche au bar
pourtant
il faut savoir parfois ralentir la
cadence
quand comment sont nées
au ventre là parce qu'on sait pas trop
ce qu'on va faire dans la saison on est
sur la fin on sait que c'est la période
de mauvais ton sec on fait encore plus
attention parce qu'on a envie de la
finir la saison à quinze 15 jours trois
semaines près
en fait on s'est quand même attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
et le meilleur pour la fin
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour soi sont
là en tout cas je sais pas quand tu le
vois dans ta caisse là c'est malheureux
ce qui lui arrive mais bon ben je sais
pas comment je pourrais le décrire
pas un chasseur comme nous enfin jeu
comparez souvent
un pêcheur patois il m'avait dit fais ça
pour se nourrir enfin il vient là toi
comme nous il se nourrit en fin de
compte
un peu plus au sud au même moment
jean courseaux le garde-pêche met les
gaz
[Musique]
thierry et marque les pêcheurs de
pouces-pieds pense avoir repéré les
braconniers
la guerre des espagnols
ils sont quatre à bord plutôt bien
équipé pour une partie de chasse sous
marine
un seul détail il n'y a qu'un seul fusil
à bord est pas une ceinture de l'est tu
les prends avec moi je ramène ordonnac
moi j'emmène orthodoxe jean le
garde-pêche a beau fouiller le navire il
ne trouve aucune trace de pouces pieds
à chaque fois ce que savait que tu
attends
[Musique]
l'un des braconniers présumés est
embarqué sur le bateau du garde-pêche il
fait mine de ne pas comprendre les
questions qu'on lui pose
golf l'un va en faire route pour les
gamins parce que face à prévenir aussi
la la la brigade de d'envoyer du monde
parce que ça ça chante dur ça chauffe
dur
de fiction d'un auteur du mélange à bord
ils sont arrivés dans un monde
[Musique]
et la situation s'envenime encore plus
lorsque les espagnoles soupçonnent
thierry et marc d'avoir jeté quelques
pouces pieds sur leur embarcation
il reviendra à quito mais la vieille
dame diane est ignoble et je suis
vraiment les bousculades coups la date
provient les gendarmes maritimes arrive
enfin à la rescousse 1 mais nos pêcheurs
vont vite déchanter
aucun flagrant délit n'est constatée les
espagnols repartent libre on peut dire
qu'ils ont eu la chance sans notre
présence thierry aurait sans aucun doute
mis à l'oeuvre ses anciens talents de
boxeur
et puis sur le travers du bateau oui je
suis en train de penser au large de
paimpol quentin newton le pêcheurs de
coquilles est loin d'imaginer qu'il est
observé abordé le bateau sur le côté ça
nous permettrait de voir s'il est
attendu à l'arrière du bateau c'est le
tome est régulièrement l'hélicoptère de
la gendarmerie participe à la
surveillance de la pêche à la coquille
les marins l'ont surnommé l'oiseau bleu
il le redoute plus que tout
tel un oiseau de proie il survole la
zone à haute altitude
à l'issue des 45 minutes de pêche sa
caméra thermique lui permet de détecter
la moindre infraction
il est 13 heures précises fin de partie
sur la baie
à partir de cet instant si les dragues
ne sont pas clairement visible sur les
flancs du navire
les pêcheurs risquent une lourde amende
et une confiscation de leur licence
trois cailloux fait
dès qu'on quitte trois bus et les vélos
la baguette à faro
[Musique]
ja j'ai pas de mots trop durs
des jolis tableaux
ils ont besoin qu'il connaît il connaît
les foules abeilles que les connaît par
coeur ça fait 40 ans qu'il les arpentent
dans tous les sens avant avec son père
et avec deux bateaux est maintenant en
tant que patron depuis et depuis je sais
pas à 25 ou 30 ans kylie kylie à son
compte
et puis bah on se connaît bien
on sait que même s'il fait mauvais le
bateau va il tient bon et des fois il
vient fort sur le côté il prendre la
gippe mais il ira pas plus loin
et puis c'est comme ça qu'ils ont fait
confiance au patron parce que c'est lui
qu'elle aborde manière donc c'est lui
tout est entre guillemets îles à sion il
a notre destin entre ses mains c'est lui
qui à notre taille et notre destin entre
ses mains donc on est obligé de faire
confiance en cette veille de noël
jean-jacques le patron de la rose de
jéricho avait choisi un terrain de
chasse mouvementée un peu plus au large
que les autres
une fois de plus son instinct ne l'a pas
trompé
faut-il sous la neige gage
à 840 kg plus grands shows 60 kilos de
roches au et 900 kg au 3 août trois
quarts d'heure et du mauvais temps ça a
démarré comme ça je signe j'aime tous
les jours c'est le minimum pour dire
ouais s'il pourrait bonne journée après
quand tu es une tonne de ouais c'est une
très bonne journée hilton 5 une tonne
dit cela tu commences à la sourire
jusqu'aux oreilles et secte à gagner du
fric
l'équipage de la rose de jéricho
remporte donc cette manche haut la main
des plus maintenant se partager un peu
moins de 2000 euros
à ouessant jean-marc jette une dernière
fois ses lignes dans la mer en furie
ces genres
ouais où tu es là moi je te vois pas
j'arrive là a dit allaoui a bon tu
arrives ou bien à ok ok très bien et 10
mois faucon speed parce que sinon on va
louper la bombe
donc tu as beaucoup embarqué dans
d'accord d'accord très bien ok parce que
là on est à la bourre il est au moins 15
en route vers le continent
jean-marc récupère la cargaison de
poisson d'un vieux copain de l'île de
sein dans le monde des ligneurs
solitaire et j'ai remarqué que l'amitié
étaient rares mais jean-marc mickeler 2
îliens se connaissent depuis longtemps
il y a quelques années encore leur père
pêcher ensemble
un appel a crié là il m'a dit tu as fait
but
à voir
il n'y a pas beaucoup de bars cela créé
une antenne du prix vermeille
pêcher le bar à la ligne où il s'était
fait quelque chose qui était qui me
tenait à coeur depuis toujours donc
forcément là j'y suis depuis douze 12 13
ans là je finirai comme ça sans doute un
j'espère on va dire voilà maintenant les
pêcher un poisson à la ligne c'est pas
venu
toutes manières enfin pour pour le
pêcheur c'est ya pas mieux quoi c'est
pour moi
voilà pour moi étant pêcheurs et je peux
pas parler au nom des autres mais en
tout cas pour mon casque
et je trouve pas d'autres satisfactions
que ça
beaucoup de prix pour le bal
jean-marc préfèrent se taire quand au
résultat de sa pêche à l'image de tous
les marins que nous avons filmé il garde
ses secrets
car le monde de la pêche ressemble à une
petite famille tourmenté où chacun tente
de trouver sa place est de survivre
comme il peut
malgré les jalousies et les règlements
de compte en tout genre sur la côte
sauvage de quiberon
thierry et marques n'ont plus qu'une
heure de travail avant que la mer ne
recouvre les pouces pieds
on aime bien la balle du tout rassuré du
moment qu'on aime bon j'ai mon ange
gardien avec est là et on est
professionnel avant tout donc
on prend des risques mesurés et on
n'avait rien à perdre ça pour vivre dont
on n'a pas le moindre but il faut qu'on
aille au bout et c'est ça qui fait
bouillir la marmite
tout est donc une question d'équilibré
entre des conditions de mer extrême du
danger du jeu et le salaire qui va avec
en filmant ses marins je cerne un peu
mieux la force du lien qui les unit
j'aime bien mon boulot mais d'arriver
ici c'est plus facile
je conçois même pas les pouces qui sans
marco marco demain il n'y ait maladie
peut plus il peut plus faire les
bustiers j'arrête des pouces pieds c'est
pas la peine je m'entendais pas avec
quelqu'un d'autre comme je m'entends
avec lui c'est pas la peine j'essaierai
même pas c'est mon ombre voilà c'est ma
jambe droite je sache en bon c'est comme
ça
marcourt je lui dois la vie 50 x et
c'est vers ce travail c'est pas un gros
trésor ils sont pas mal travaillé sont
pas coupés dans un 50 kg et donc comme
on est des modestes jambes on se
contente d'une modeste journée ou alors
mais si j'étais avec un mec était aussi
bon mois au tableau de s'y allonger
[Musique]
la pêche maigre certains mais après
cette journée mouvementée nos deux
compères ont au moins une consolation
ils ont limité la casse et sont encore
entier
[Musique]
retour d'un temps plus calme sur la
bretagne
nous souhaitions vous montrer ses
pêcheurs tels que nous les connaissons
désormais les hommes de mer à la fois
sensible et abrupte 1 ils sont
finalement à l'image du décor naturel
qui les entoure
quentin newton a retrouvé son archipel
de bréhat égard de son rêve dans un coin
de sa tête
malgré toutes les difficultés
rencontrées il compte bien un jour
devenir lui aussi patron de pêche 24
autres
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais beaucoup avoir un jour mon
bateau et faire sa mère ce métier là
toute ma famille et compte depuis des
années depuis que je suis gamin mes
parents voulaient pas que je fasse à
pêche
il y en a souvent qu'ils disent pourquoi
tu arrêtes pas ce métier là ce que
j'aime sans est temps que ça pourra me
permettre de vivre et faire quelque
chose qui me plaît d'être en plein air
des dehors je vois qu'on nous pose
j'arrêterai
[Applaudissements]
après une pêche mémorable jean-marc
guilcher arrive en vue de son minuscule
rocher de la mer d'iroise ou sa famille
l'attend même s'il ne peut pas vivre sur
l'île de sein toute l'année c'est ici
que de temps à autre il puise le courage
et l'audace de repartir dans les
déferlantes
je prends les bouteilles corps voyages
et bien équipée la vie des vrais galles
il est vrai était vrai cap
j'avais jamais sauter à bord on va
avancer un plan pénal
quand il ya déjà une belle pêche sur le
pont et comprend encore des risques pour
aller chercher trois poissons et donc ça
une fois sont plus ceux qui seront pas
raisonnable du tout quoi mais ça on s'en
rend compte qu'avec d'expérience avec
les mets moi qui passe et les années qui
passent
l'arrière maman il disait je suis plus
raisonnable maintenant qu'il ya quelques
années
le fait d'être père de faire de vieillir
aussi je pense que ça fait partie du jeu
quoi
[Musique]
la vôtre
le corps
[Musique]
sur le port de quiberon thierry et marc
ont tenu à ce que nous goûtions les
fameux pouces pieds
[Musique]
ils ont le goût du risque et un parfum
des crimes dit il
wingles
un peu plus tard cette nuit là j'ai
enfin compris ce que signifiait le nom
de ce restaurant un nom ou plutôt une
expression bretonne qui résument à elles
seules ces trois histoires de mer pour
moi elle prend ici tout son sens nitra
mpn on n'a rien sans peine